>> GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME TO A
LIVE SPECIAL EDITION OF
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
I AM MARK STEYN IN THE FOR
TUCKER WHO IS TAKING A QUIET
FISHING WEEKEND, BUT HE WILL BE
DROPPING BY MOMENTARILY.
CHINA IS A NUMBER ONE GLOBAL
POWER.
WHAT HAPPENED TO AMERICA?
SOMETIMES YOU GET DEALT SOME
TOUGH GEOPOLITICAL CARDS AS
BRITAIN, FRANCE, SPAIN, PORTUGAL
COULD SURELY ALL TELL US BUT
SOMETIMES, YOU JUST DO IT TO
YOURSELF.
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE STORIES
THAT WOULD'VE BEEN RATHER DULL
SATIRE A DECADE AGO BUT NOW IT
IS STANDARD OPERATING PROCEDURE.
FROM A GROUP CALLED DALLAS
JUSTICE NOW, AN OPEN LETTER TO
WEALTHY WHITE LIBERALS.
"TO OUR WHITE ALLIES, TALK IS
NOT ENOUGH, COMMIT YOURSELF
TOWARDS TAKING ACTION AND MAKING
SACRIFICES TO CORRECT CENTURIES
OF INJUSTICE, OPEN UP SPACES FOR
BLACK AND LATIN COMMUNITIES BY
REFUSING TO SEND YOUR KIDS TO
IVY LEAGUE AND "U.S. NEWS &
WORLD REPORT" TOP 50 SCHOOLS AND
ENCOURAGE FRIENDS, NEIGHBORS,
AND FAMILY MEMBERS TO DO THE
SAME.
IMAGINE IF THOSE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF SPOTS OF THESE
INSTITUTIONS WERE OCCUPIED ONLY
BY LOOK MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES.
IMAGINE THE OPPORTUNITIES.
WE CAN ACHIEVE TRUE EQUITY
WITHIN OUR LIFETIMES BUT ONLY IF
WHITE FOLKS ARE WILLING TO
SACRIFICE THEIR PRIVILEGES."
YES, INDEED IT'S NOT ENOUGH FOR
YOU NICE WHITE ALLIES JUST TO
LISTEN TO NPR AND GIGGLE AT HOW
STUPID ALL THE WHITE MALE
DIFFERENCES ARE IN COMMERCIALS
NOWADAYS AND ADMIRE HOW THAT
SPLENDID U.S. LADIES SOCCER TEAM
IS SO COMMITTED TO GETTING THE
TAKING THE NEW STUFF JUST LIKE
THAT THEY'VE GIVEN UP ALL
SCORING.
THESE ARE MERE GESTURES.
THEY COST YOU NOTHING.
BUT ARE USED EFFICIENTLY ALL
INTO TICKET IT TO THE NEXT LEVEL
OF CHILD SACRIFICE?
AT LEAST AS FAR AS EDUCATION IS
CONCERNED.
HERE'S HOW THE PLEDGE GOES.
AS A WHITE PERSON WITH
PRIVILEGE, BOTH FROM MY
WHITENESS AND MY NEIGHBORHOOD, I
REALIZE THE IDEA OF MAKING
SACRIFICES TO CORRECT HUNDREDS
OF YEARS OF MURDER, SLAVERY,
DISCRIMINATION, AND LACK OF
EDUCATIONAL AND ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES PERPETRATED AMONG
PEOPLE OF COLOR.
I UNDERSTAND THAT ACCESS TO TOP
SCHOOLS IS A KEY COMPONENT IN
ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL ADVANCEMENT,
THEREFORE I COMMEND LET MY
CHILDREN WILL NOT APPLY TO OR
ATTEND ANY IVY LEAGUE SCHOOL OR
U.S. NEWS AND WORLD TOP 50
SCHOOL SO THAT POSITION IS
AVAILABLE FOR PEOPLE OF COLOR TO
HELP CORRECT HISTORICAL WRONGS.
DON'T BE A RACIST HYPOCRITE,
SIGN THE PLEDGE TODAY.
AND JUST IN CASE YOU WERE
THINKING OF TOSSING IT ON THE
PILE WITH THE SUPERMARKET
COUPONS AND THE PUBLISHERS
CLEARING HOUSE YOU MAY HAVE
ALREADY WON POSTCARDS, DALLAS
JUSTICE AT THIS MORNING.
"BUT DALLAS JUST AS NOW WILL BE
PUBLICLY ANNOUNCING THE NAMES OF
THOSE WHO HAVE AND HAVE NOT
SIGNED THE PLEDGE."
SO IF YOU WHITE LIBERAL ALLIES
CAN POINT TO YOUR TAX-DEDUCTIBLE
DONATION TO THE EL PASO FESTIVAL
OF ASPIRING RAPPERS ISN'T GOING
TO CUT IT ANYMORE.
IT THE OVERWORKED FAMILY FROM
TEXAS TRIED THAT WITH THEIR CUTE
MIDDLE SCHOOL OR WHO NEVER
MISSED AN OPPORTUNITY TO
EXCORIATE HIMSELF.
>> AS A WHITE MAN WHO HAS HAD
PRIVILEGES THAT OTHERS COULD NOT
DEPEND ON OR TAKE FOR GRANTED,
I'VE CLEARLY HAD ADVANTAGES OVER
THE COURSE OF MY LIFE.
>> THE WAY IN WHICH I
ACKNOWLEDGE THE TRUTH AND THE
CRITICISM THAT I HAVE BEEN
JOINED BY PRIVILEGE ABSOLUTELY
UNDENIABLE.
>> YOU ARE RIGHT, THERE ARE
THINGS I HAVE BEEN PRIVILEGED TO
DO IN MY LIFE THAT OTHERS
CANNOT.
>> NOT BECAUSE I'M A GREAT
PERSON OR A GENIUS, A LOT OF IT
HAS TO DO WITH THE FACT THAT I
AM A WHITE MAN.
>> Mark: OKAY, SO DID YOU GIVE
UP YOUR PLACE AT COLUMBIA
UNIVERSITY CURRENTLY THIRD IN
THE NATION AND LET THE FAMILY
POOL BOY GO INSTEAD?
NO.
HE MAJORED IN SKATEBOARDING WITH
A MINOR IN AIR GUITAR AND WROTE
HIS MASTERS THESIS ON
SOCIO-RACIAL SELF-FLAGELLATION
AS IDENTITY POLITICS.
YOU WERE A PERSON OF COLOR, YOU
MIGHT EVENTUALLY SUSPECT THAT
HIS CONSTANT CONFESSIONS OF HIS
PRIVILEGE OR SIMPLY AN EASY WAY
FOR HIM TO MAINTAIN IT.
IN THE 19 CENTURY, THEY MADE THE
BIG BUCKS BY BEING A BLACK FACED
MINSTRELS.
IN THE 20TH CENTURY, THEY MADE
BIG BUCKS BY DOING SAFE COVER
VERSIONS OF BLACK MUSIC AND NOW
IN THE 21ST CENTURY, WHITE GUYS
IN THIS CASE A WHITE GUY WHO WAS
LIGHTER THAN ANY WHITE GUY YOU
HAVE SEEN SINCE "LEAVE IT TO
BEAVER," THESE WHITE GUYS MAKE
THE BIG BUCKS BY TELLING ALL THE
OTHER WHITES BE LESS BITE.
PROFESSOR SAM WILLIAMS OF THE
WRETCHED PENN STATE UNIVERSITY
HOSTS AN UTTERLY WORTHLESS
CLASS.
>> TO BE LESS WHITENESS TO BE
LESS CERTAIN, DEFENSIVE,
IGNORANT, BE MORE HUMBLE,
LISTEN, BELIEVE, BREAK WITH
PARTY AND BREAK WITH SOLIDARITY.
>> IT'S MORE OR LESS JUST
RECOGNIZING WHAT YOU HAVE IN
LIFE WHATEVER THAT MAY BE AND
NOT THINKING YOURSELF SUPERIOR
BECAUSE OF THAT.
>> WHAT WAY WITH PEOPLE FIND
THAT OFFENSIVE?
>> CONSERVATIVES, I GUESS.
>> WHAT'S THE POINT OF WHAT IT'S
TRYING TO SAY?
>> I DON'T WANT TO GET CANCELED
SO I'M TRYING TO BE CAREFUL WITH
WHAT I SAY.
>> WHO HAVE YOU GUYS A PRESS
MOST TODAY?
>> I HAVE AN OPPRESSED ANYONE
TODAY.
>> ARE YOU SURE OF THAT?
YOU ARE BREATHING.
HAVE YOU LEFT YOUR HOUSE TODAY?
>> YES.
>> OKAY, SO YOU MAY HAVE
OPPRESSED SOMEBODY.
>> Mark: YOU MAY HAVE
OPPRESSED SOMEBODY JUST BY
BREATHING.
WHAT A GREAT COUNTRY.
AMERICA IS THE ONLY PLACE ON
EARTH WHERE WHITES CAN BECOME
MULTI-GAZILLION ERRORS BY
DECLARING THAT ALL OTHER RIGHTS
ARE [BLEEP] HOLES.
>> WHAT IF YOU COULD JUST GIVE
US FEEDBACK ON OUR INEVITABLE
AND OFTEN UNAWARE RACIST
ASSUMPTIONS AND BEHAVIORS AND
I'LL NEVER FORGET THIS BLACK MAN
RAISING HIS HAND AND SAYING IT
WOULD BE REVOLUTIONARY.
YOU JUST TAKE THAT END, I JUST
WANT ALL THE RIGHT PEOPLE TO
TAKE THAT INCOME I REVOLUTIONARY
THAT WE WOULD RECEIVE THE
FEEDBACK WITH GRACE, REFLECT AND
THINK TO CHANGE OUR BEHAVIOR.
THAT'S HOW DIFFICULT WE ARE.
THAT'S HOW BIG OF A HOLES WE
ARE.
>> Mark: WHITE LIBERALS, DON'T
FORGET TO PREORDER THE
FORTHCOMING BOOK WHILE YOU'RE
YOU'RE A PATHETIC RACIST [BLEEP]
HOLE AND BUYING THIS BOOK ISN'T
GOING TO CHANGE THAT SO DALLAS
JUSTICE NOW HAS CORRECTLY IF
VERY BELATEDLY GRASPED THAT THE
WHITE LIBERALS TEDIOUS PANTOMIME
OF FAKE CIVILIZATIONAL DISAVOWAL
AND PSEUDO-SELF-LOATHING IS IN
GETTING THEM ANYWHERE AND THEY
ARE DEMANDING THAT THEY ACTUALLY
FORSWEAR COLUMBIA UNIVERSITY AND
ITS FELLOW TEXAS LIBERALS DO
LIKEWISE.
THIS IS WIN-WIN, YOUR KID WILL
LEARN JUST AS MUCH AT DEAD
BUZZARD JUNCTION COMMUNITY
COLLEGE EXCEPT FOR THE BASKET
WEAVING AND PUPPETRY WHICH IS
HARDER THAN IT LOOKS AT LEAST
WHEN COMPARED TO TRANSGENDER AND
COLONIALISM STUDIES BUT DALLAS
JUSTICE NOW IS NOT GOING FAR
ENOUGH.
THEY SHOULD BE PUBLICLY FALLING
TO GIVE AWAY THEIR BLOOD-SOAKED
ENDOWMENTS TO HISTORICALLY BLACK
COLLEGES, SHIP IT STRAIGHT TO
AFRICA, GIVE IT TO THE SCHOOL OF
PUBLIC INTEGRITY.
COURTESY OF THE OFFICIAL
GOVERNMENT STATISTICS 2019 PAID
50 GRAND A YEAR FOR THE
OCCASIONAL ZOOM CALL, SO WHO
KNOWS HOW THE 2020 STATS WILL
SHAKE OUT THE JUST FOR THE
RECORD, THE PERCENTAGE OF 18 TO
24-YEAR-OLDS ENROLLED IN COLLEGE
BY RACE, WHITES 41%, BLACK 37%.
THAT WOULD BE MARGIN OF ERROR
TERRITORY WE WERE DISCUSSING
WHETHER MITT ROMNEY OR LIZ
CHENEY WAS AHEAD IN THE LATEST
IOWA.
ASIANS ARE ON TOP AT 62% BUT
UNLESS YOU ARE A WHITE
FIFTH-GRADER GETTING HIS KICKED
IN THE COUNTY MATH LEAGUE
COMPETITION, YOU CAN'T MENTION
THAT.
IN SECOND PLACE THAT 47%,
PERSONS OF TWO OR MORE RACES SO
THIS MIGHT WANT TO CALL FOR THE
REINTRODUCTION OF WHAT'S THAT
WORD THAT DEMOCRATS SAY?
AND IN THIRD PLACE, BY THE WAY,
AT 43% OF PACIFIC ISLANDERS
BECAUSE WE ALL KNOW THAT
WHEREVER YOU TURN IN AMERICAN
LIFE, ALL THE GUYS RUNNING
EVERYTHING, CEOs, UNIVERSITY
PRESIDENTS, STUDIO HEADS ARE ALL
SAMOAN.
SOCIAL JUSTICE WARRIORS INSTEAD
OF COMPLAINING ABOUT
MICROAGGRESSIONS SHOULD BE
COMPLAINING ABOUT MICRONESIAN
AGGRESSIONS.
THAT'S IT BACK IN THE REAL WORLD
BUT IN THE REAL, REAL WORLD,
EDUCATION IS AND SUPPOSED TO BE
ABOUT EVERYTHING ALREADY
SUCCESSIVELY HIGH LEVELS TO
NUCLEAR STRENGTH BUT ABOUT
BORING STUFF LIKE ARITHMETIC,
LITERATURE, PHYSICS.
HOW ARE WE DOING THERE?
IN MATH, CHINA IS NUMBER ONE.
THERE'S A SURPRISE, CHINA NUMBER
ONE AND AMERICA -- LET ME SEE
HERE.
ESTONIA, SLOVENIA, SLOVAKIA, CAN
YOU SCROLL DOWN A BIT?
HERE WE ARE, NUMBER 37, THE
UNITED STATES JUST AHEAD OF
BASKET CASE BELARUS.
WHITE LIBERALS IN DALLAS SHOULD
JUST AGREE TO SEND THEIR KIDS TO
SCHOOLS IN BELARUS.
SAME RESULTS BUT A LOT CHEAPER
EVEN WITH THE COST OF THE PLANE
TICKETS.
TO GO BACK TO THOSE, 43% OF
PACIFIC ISLANDERS, 37% OF BLACKS
ARE IN COLLEGE.
THOSE NUMBERS ARE ALL WAY TOO
HIGH BECAUSE MOST OF THOSE
STUDENTS ARE NOT LEARNING
ANYTHING WORTH KNOWING OF
STAYING IN SCHOOL UNTIL GRADE 38
IS A WASTE OF LIFE.
EACH YEAR, CHINA GRADUATES
GETTING CLOSE TO TEN TIMES MORE
STEM STUDENTS THAN AMERICA DOES
BECAUSE STEM IS DIFFICULT AND
GIVING CLASSICS AT PRINCETON
WHERE YOU KNOW LONGER NEED TO
KNOW THAT IN THEIR GREEK OR
ENGLISH AT YALE WHERE YOU KNOW
LONGER NEED TO KNOW SHAKESPEARE
ISN'T DIFFICULT AT ALL.
CHINESE EDUCATORS THINK MATH IS